معلنا أنه وصل إلى طريق مسدود ، قدم
رئيس الوزراء اللبناني ، السرج الحريري
، استقالة حكومة الوحدة الوطنية
إلى الرئيس ميشا على سبيل الإعارة ،
حيث علق بين الاحتجاجات الجماهيرية على مستوى البلاد
وشركائه في
حكومة كانت على الرغم من اسمها
منقسمة بشدة كما أوضح البلد
عندما  مئات الرجال بعضهم يرددون
شعارات مؤيدة لحزب الله اندلعوا
في ساحة الشهداء حيث
المعسكر الرئيسي للمحتجين المناهضين للحكومة في
العاصمة ، ثم انتقلوا إلى الساحة الواقعة
على الطريق من رئيس الوزراء في
مواجهة قوات الأمن
التي لم يسلمها من هذا الاشتباك.
سبقتها اشتباكات بين
المتظاهرين والسكان المحليين الغاضبين
من تكتيك إغلاق الطرق الذي يهدف إلى
وضع البلاد في طريق مسدود ،
لكنها تضر باللبنانيين الذين يعانون من ضغوط شديدة والذين
يعيشون جنبًا إلى جنب تحت
ضغط اقتصاد على وشك الانهيار
[  موسيقى]
من يعمل بأجر يومي
لا يستطيع أن يشتري الطعام يقول علي حميد وهو
سائق لم أعمل منذ ذلك الحين  بدأ
بحلول المساء ، عاد المتظاهرون
إلى الساحات على الرغم من قلة عددهم
احتفلوا بسقوط الحكومة
انتصارًا من نوع ما ، لكن مطالبهم
بوضع حد للفساد الرسمي
والسياسة الطائفية بعيدة كل البعد عن
تلبية الحكومة ، أعني أنها كاملة
النظام هو منظمة كاملة
للمسؤولين الآن وتحتاج إلى
ذلك نحتاج إلى إسقاط
استقالة الحكومة يفتح
فراغًا سياسيًا خطيرًا في بلد
مزقته أسبوعين من الاحتجاجات
ويواجه الانهيار الاقتصادي أيامًا محفوفة بالمخاطر
تنتظر بن ويدمان.  سي إن إن بيروت